يوم الخميس قبل عيد الميلاد وفق التقويم
الشرقي اتصلان للرئيس التركي احدهما مع
نظيره الروسي والاخر مع الاوكراني في
اتصاله مع بوتا دعاء اردوغان الى اعلان
وقف اطلاق نار من طرف واحد بعد ساعات
قليله قال الرئيس التركي لنظيره الاوكراني
ان بلاده مستعده للوساطه من اجل سلام دائم
بينك ومسكو في اليوم نفسه اعلن رئيس
الروسي هدنه من طرف واحد لس 36 سنه بدات
الهدنه وفق الاعلان الروسي ظهر الجمعه
وتنتهي منتصف ليله الاحد رافقتها مطالبه
روسيه لاوكرانيا بوقف اطلاق النار كذلك
ليعيش الناس طقوس العيد رفضته اوكرانيا
لهنه الروسيه راها الرئيس الاوكراني مجرد
خدعه لوقف التقدم الاخرانيه في الميدان
مستشار رئاسه الاوكرانيه اشترط الانسحاب
الروسيه الكامل للموافقه على الهدنه بنفس
زاويه الاخرانيه ينظر الرئيس الامريكي
يقول بايدينا نظيره الروسي الى متنفس لا
غير لا يبتعد الموقف الاوربي كثيرا وشرطه
يقول مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان الهدنه الروسيه تفتقر الى
المصداقيه ومحاولتها روسيا لتجميل صورتها
الدوليه تواصل القتال في الميدان وخيم
السجال والاتهامات المتبادله على اول هدنه
في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا